[Musique]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle lorenza tri
g 20 ans je suis étudiante en ingénierie
spatiale et j'ai constamment la tête
dans les étoiles
je rêve de devenir une astronaute je
rêve de monter sur scène tous les jours
de sortir mon album de musique d'être
une chanteuse connue de faire un volant
zéro gravité de développer un rover de
monter ma propre entreprise
bref j'ai beaucoup trop de projets en
tête pour une seule vie et à chaque fois
que je rencontre quelqu'un j'ai qu'une
envie c'est de connaître ses rêves les
plus fous et ses passions les plus
improbables
alors aujourd'hui j'ai une question pour
vous est-ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé
d'avoir une idée de génie ou du moins
quelque chose que vous pensiez être une
idée de génie un moment où une pensée
s'est immiscé dans votre esprit et vous
vous êtes mis à imaginer tout un futur
autour je suis sûr que ça vous est déjà
arrivé au moins une fois que vous
cherchez consciemment innover ou pas
presque tout le monde crie au quotidien
dans ses pensées des produits
révolutionnaires de science-fiction ou
des romans dindin histoire romantique
toute création a du potentiel à être
développé exploite et est produite
pourtant parmi tous ces rêveurs peu
d'entre eux poussent leur créativité
assez loin pour passer du stade de
l'idée à celui d'un réel projet signé
alors qu'est-ce qui ne retient pour moi
c'est simple et ça tient en deux mots
les risques quels sont les premiers
risques qui vous vient en tête quand
vous pensez au développement d'un
produit
pour moi c'est le risque financier est
ce que mon produit est viable sur le
marché est-ce que je peux le
subventionner moi même est-ce que j'ai
besoin d'actionnaires derrière j'ai tout
de suite pensé au risque de l'impact
social c'est à dire est ce que mon
projet peut apporter quelque chose à la
société
est ce que au contraire il peut être
nuisible nocifs ou dangereux pour le
consommateur ou est-ce qu'il peut être
boycottés ou faire polémique
difficile de mesurer tout ça quand on
n'est pas banquier et responsable
marketing et à la fois
pourtant toutes ces questions sont
légitimes et se recentre autour d'une
seule réelle problématique la survie est
le bien-être du produit avant le début
de cette année scolaire
jamais je ne m'étais préoccuper d'une
chose qui pourtant est fondamentale la
survie et le bien-être n'ont pas de
l'innovation mais de l'innovateur je n'y
voyais même pas de problème tant que je
ne craquait pas pour moi le sacrifice
était une notion inhérentes au concept
même d'innovation peu de gens
considèrent l'énergie psychologique
comme une ressource à part entière comme
le temps où l'argent il n'y voit même
pas de problème donc tout fonctionne
cela devient donc difficile de mesurer
les risques du manque de cette ressource
cette énergie peut être utilisé comme
l'énergie renouvelable mais simon la
seiche
elle se transformera en énergies
fossiles aujourd'hui j'aimerais qu'on
analyse ensemble les risques du manque
de cette ressource est commencé cette
ressource peut impacter l'innovation
alors pour cela
imaginez que là maintenant tout de suite
vous vous lancer dans un projet alors la
thématique de notre tedx aujourd'hui
c'est sauter le pas on a en tête que
sauter le pas c'est ultra simple dit
comme ça tu mets une jambe devant
l'autre et c'est bon t'as sauter le pas
mais concrètement il ya deux aspects au
fait sauter le pas il ya d'un côté le
fait de prendre la décision sur le long
terme et de l'autre la mettre en place
au quotidien
alors quand vous avez la possibilité par
exemple de vous inscrire pour faire un
tedx vous avez deux possibilités
différentes soit vous pouvez vous dire
j'ai toujours rêvé de faire un top 6
mais je sais pas si j'ai le temps de le
faire je sais pas si mon idéal colle à
la thématique je sais pas de quoi parler
peut-être une autre fois soit vous
pouvez vous dire ok j'ai une petite idée
je suis pas sûr de là où je veux pour
l'instant mais j'ai vraiment envie de me
lancer
allez j'y vais et j'arrive et on verra
bien si j'arrive à écrire un tel style
plaît vous vous doutez bien quelle était
ma réaction
ce qui est difficile pour les rêveurs
comme moi c'est de sauter des petits pas
des petits pas qui additionné les uns
aux autres deviennent le grand saut
alors une fois qu'on a sauté le grand
pas on va commencer par faire pas mal de
planification par exemple je peux me
dire alors lundi je finis travail à 19
heures et du couffo chaumont se
mobiliser ce moment à 19h30 pour que
derrière mercredi entre midi et deux
faces la planification au budget et
vous voyez où est le problème ou plutôt
les problèmes en l'occurrence rien que
la phrase déjà eu beaucoup trop longue
mes premiers vrais problèmes en disant
que je vais commencer une tâche à une
certaine heure semble donner d'heure de
faim je n'ai probablement jamais
m'arrêter
et je ne vous apprends probablement rien
mais c'est sûrement le meilleur moyen de
ne jamais s'y mettre si je ne mets pas
de faim à une tâche définie
je veux juste voir devant moi une énorme
montagne que je ne voudrais jamais
escaladé en mettant en temps de faim
certes un peu arbitraire
je vais augmenter ma motivation est
drastiquement diminué mon envie de
m'adonner à des pratiques bien plus
stimulant sur le court terme ou dit plus
simplement
j'aurai mon a la flemme mal non deuxième
erreur dans mon plan d'action ne pas se
fixer des marges raisonnables
c'est à dire que en me disant qu' il
faut impérativement que je finisse mon
business plan dans la soirée en fait
c'est pas du tout faisable donc il faut
toujours se fixer à une marge
il faut se fixer c'est deadline de
manière raisonnable maintenant qu'elle
était la troisième erreur dans mon plan
d'action la possibilité de me perdre
dans les détails parce que vous l'avez
déjà sûrement remarqué mais presque tout
le monde qui se lance dans un projet qui
leur tient à coeur de vienne
perfectionniste parce que le projet nous
tient tellement à coeur est tellement
important à nos yeux qui on va juste
vouloir que tout se passe parfaitement
de la manière dont on l'envisagé mais
parfois les détails qui sur le moment
paraît une importance énorme ne sont pas
si nécessaire vous ne croyez pas ok on
va faire un test qui dans cette salle a
remarqué que la troisième boîte de mon
texte n'était pas parfaitement alignés
avec le reste moi est bon peut-être une
ou deux personnes mais c'est un peu tout
parce que perdre du temps sur la mise en
forme c'est peut-être ma spécialité je
sais que dans ces moments là ce que je
fais c'est excessif
que je passe 10 heures dessus mais
pourtant j'arrive pas à m'arrêter parce
que je me dis que tout le monde verra
ses détails alors quand je sais que si
je commence à faire du design et que si
je me lance je vais jamais m'arrêter
et bah qu'est ce que je fais je me lance
pas je le délègue tout simplement à
quelqu'un d'autre qui va me le faire en
une heure grand max parce que je sais qu
pas en école de design
je suis en école d'ingénieur donc je
sais que ce qui compte dans un rapport
d'ingénieur
c'est le raisonnement qu'il ya derrière
jamais un actionnaire va venir me voir
et me dire oui non désolé on aime
beaucoup votre projet mais les couleurs
de votre logo n était pas très rares
moyens entraîne on va pas vous donner
les fous allez au revoir
bon maintenant petite histoire à part
qu'elle était la plus grave erreur de
bons plans d'action vous souvenez tous
de bons plans d'action bien sûr je
répète je vais faire l'analyse du budget
mercredi entre midi et deux ok très bien
lorenza tu feras centre-ville de pas de
souci mais tu manges pas en fait devant
ton ordi pendant que tu montres ton
projet alors bon exceptionnellement une
fois de temps en temps mais qui et
pourquoi pas mais pas si ce n'est pas
nécessaire et encore moins si ce n'est
pas urgent une chose qu'on oublie
tellement rapidement mais il faut
toujours se fixer des limites et des
routines dites vous que tous les jours
vous ne travaillez pas avant une
certaine heure vous ne travaillez pas
après une certaine heure et vous de
travail et surtout pas pendant les repas
c'est primordial pour tout le monde
d'avoir un moment dans chaque journée où
il peut reprendre de l'énergie et
planifier les jours à venir
votre santé psychologique et la pierre
fondatrice de votre audace est votre
enthousiasme si vous la sacrifier tout
s'effondrera et vous ne construit rien
de solide par dessus il ya pas si
longtemps que ça
j'avais épuisé tellement d'énergie que
j'avais du mal à faire face à un nouveau
jour et aux responsabilités que ça
engendrait parce que je me rendais pas
compte à l'époque
mais mon cerveau était juste un ouragan
d'idées de penser je travaillais des
semaines sans m'arrêter de jour comme de
nuit et j'étais jamais épuisé j'avais
tellement de projets en tête
j'étais constamment frustré de
travailler tout le temps j'étais
tellement heureuse de faire des choses
qui me passionnait il dirigeait
l'association de spatiale et
l'association de communication mon école
dirigé un programme international de
rover j'avais candidater pour un
programme d'étudiants astronautes
je faisais du dessin de la musique du
théâtre et j'avais un semestre validé
aussi détaillé c'est important quand
même bref une fois cet ouragan de
créativité de pensées et d'idées passé
je me suis retrouvé seul face à
l'inondation que j'ai moi même engendrer
et dans ces moments là quand je voyais
tout le monde d'avancé alors que j'avais
l'impression de couler je me suis dit
que j'étais peut-être psychologiquement
plus faible que et c'est probablement
vrai mais ce n'est pas forcément une
mauvaise chose
et laissez-moi vous expliquer pourquoi
oui je suis combative
je suis acharné je suis motivé mais je
sais que j'ai une faiblesse ma quantité
d'énergie psychologique disponible qui
fait que lorsque la charge de travail et
la pression augmente de trop je peux
craquer sauf que cette faiblesse est à
la base de ma plus grande qualité
ma créativité je ressens les choses
les tensions les mots qu'on dit et des
fois ça peut me laisser
mais c'est ce qui fait de moi qui je
suis c'est ce qui peut me permettre
d'être à la fois ingénieur et artistes
de créer des concepts mécanique
futuriste tout comme de pouvoir
ressentir la musique y est en moi c'est
ce qui me rend à la fois curieuse et
inventive alors même si pour moi et
peut-être pour d'autres il peut être
simple de tomber dans ce type de burn
out sans s'en rendre compte
tout cela est complètement évitable
à partir du moment où vous avez
conscience des risques il n'y a pas de
fatalité il faut juste être attentif
pour que jamais cette flamme qui est en
vous ne s'éteigne aujourd'hui je suis là
pour vous transmettre des outils pour
couvrir la flamme qui est en vous alors
pour résumer voici les conseils qu'il
est qui m'ont permis d'avancer dans
cette période de crise premier conseil
avant de vous lancer dans la
planification de quoi que ce soit
définissez des objectifs avec des temps
réaliste
deuxième conseil fixez-vous une marge de
temps de 10 à 20%
ça peut paraître évident mais ça vous
est déjà arrivé de passer toute une
journée à travailler sur quelque chose
qui de vous prendre qu'une heure
mettez vous un timer à chaque fois vous
démarrez quelque chose
troisième conseil ne vous perdez pas
dans les détails
certes il faut toujours adressé un
certain nombre de détails dans n'importe
quel projet car chacun d'entre eux
peuvent lui donner vie mais il faut
savoir différencier une goutte d'eau
dans un océan pour ne pas vous noyer
dans les détails
quatrième conseil fixez-vous des limites
définissez-vous des règles pour vous
reposer s'il le faut je sais que ça peut
paraître complètement contre intuitif
dit comme ça mais c'est fondamental
si vous ne le faites pas pour votre
propre bien faites-le pour le bien de
votre innovation très passer vos limites
ne vous aidera pas à concrétiser vos
projets
5ème conseil derrière chaque faiblesse
se trouve une force tout aussi grande il
ne tient qu'à vous d'utiliser cette
dualité à votre avantage
sixième et dernier conseil fait
comprendre aux personnes avec lesquelles
vous travaillez que votre santé
psychologique est primordial est
intrinsèque à vos réussites commune je
vais m'étendre un petit peu là dessus
dites-vous que qui vous soyez où que
vous soyez sur l'échelle sociale
si vous avez déjà fait un burn-out comme
moi c'est que vous avez le pouvoir
d'entreprendre parce que vous avez cette
force et cette passion vous êtes déjà
sacrifié pour quelque chose pour les
entreprises que vous dirigez les
entreprises dans lesquelles vous
travaillez des études les écoles dans
lesquelles vous travaillez et si vous
vous êtes déjà sacrifié pour eux c'est
que vous avez ce pouvoir d'entre eux
prend
et le pouvoir de faire changer les
choses par exemple j'essaie de faire
comprendre cette idée d'énergie
psychologique à l'administration de mon
école je ne suis qu étudiante
pourtant je suis arrivé devant eux avec
informe rempli par 850 élèves détaillées
sur leur énergie et leur santé
psychologique
j'ai été soutenu par différents corps
étudiant est ensemble on a pu contribuer
au changement de notre école alors
négocié négocier avec vous employez vos
employeurs avec vos collègues de travail
des accommodations des congés du
matériel n'importe quoi qui puisse aider
votre conditions de travail maintenant
oser oser avancer
oser innover et oser entreprendre merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]